welcome back to cbs mornings we're going
to share a story with you about helping
others in need no matter how they come
into our lives so think about that lead
in for just a second nearly one in three
americans say they have at some point
fallen victim to a phone scam we've all
been there in 2020 scam calls in this
country caused a total loss of nearly 30
billion dollars now we should also
mention it's really not a good idea to
engage with phone scammers i always say
i have to go to the airport and get off
the phone but as our lead national
correspondent david bagno shows us one
of those relentless phone scams actually
led to an improbable friendship
now look we all get spam calls but most
people hang them up that's right so why
did you hang it up
something in that young man's voice i
felt like i could hear him through the
phone that he was a broken person it
moved your heart it moved my heart
stephen ira adams owns an insurance
agency in central louisiana he come by
he answers that phone constantly
anonymous calls no problem it's just a
part of the business
in 2016 though he got a call that
unexpectedly moved him
what he heard on the other end of the
line was a pain
and it was a pain he knew all too well
we'll get back to that in a moment
but the man on the other end of the line
was at a call center in ghana africa and
he was asking adams to purchase a gift
card i said to him what you're doing
right now is is a scam you are targeting
elderly americans
and it's not right
and i said when you get off call me so
when he called you back did he continue
to ask you for money
he did not ever ask me for any money
ever again
nope he did not he asked me for mosquito
nets malaria drugs
educational things the man asking for
that was prince anderson
he's from a small village in ghana
as the oldest son in the family when his
father died he took on the duty of
caring for his sick mother and for
supporting his younger brother through
school
it has now been five years since they
first spoke
and anderson and adams are still in
touch over facetime the kind of love he
showed me
you know the things he sent me you know
the money and the care of love you know
my mom and everything the love he showed
me it's overwhelming prince anderson is
now 25
stephen ira adams is 41 and he's a dad
to two boys
he told us he also sees himself as a
father figure to prince i told him to
quit that call center and he never went
back
because he found out what it was about
some of the people working there i found
out don't even know what's going on
his next job after he quit that call
center he was washing windows at the
airport as of today prince anderson is
now working for a private security
company in the capital of ghana
and in a twist of fate his brother isaac
anderson got a scholarship to howard
university in washington dc where he
recently started his freshman year
and when the dorms closed for winter
break
adams invited isaac to spend christmas
with him and the family in alexandria
louisiana how do you refer to isaac
isaac sometimes i say son no say my dad
yeah you call him your dad yeah i seem
to be my father because
the kind of things he's doing for me
care and all that
he's a tough man like really top a tough
man
they may look like an unlikely family
but adam said that he learned early on
as a boy about the enduring power of
kindness
coming from strangers from where i came
from in life to where i'm at now is a
journey as well tell me about where you
came from uh i was uh born to very young
parents he revealed to us details about
a tumultuous childhood that he says
included abuse abandonment and poverty
we're not going to make it by ourselves
in this world you know especially at
that young age there was a restaurant
beside us and when they were closing
dumping the stuff out oh i went over
there i was like i'll take them potato
logs
the people at the restaurant found out
that we were there by ourselves you know
nobody called the authorities we had a
neighbor an older lady that was a
neighbor she'd kind of check in on us so
i learned how to survive there
he wound up in foster care for a brief
period
and then was raised by his grandmother
and his grandfather who was a u.s air
force veteran
and he says his grandfather instilled in
him a profound love of country
and he says that's what led him to serve
his country himself you've experienced
abandonment
abuse poverty
food deprivation
yes i have
yep yep but i had the opportunity to
pull myself out of it in the united
states of america though and you said
you've always been a caretaker yes
because you had to take care of yourself
take care of that for so long yeah yeah
and then my younger siblings as well so
that's where this goodness comes from
it comes from pain it comes from pain it
comes from being coming from pain yeah
absolutely right you've been searching
all your life
because you've been looking for
consistency you've been looking for
stability stability you have been
looking for stability absolutely yep i
think about when i was younger the
different random people that helped me
everything from neighbors to people i
met on my bicycle to the janitors at my
high school yeah to the lunchroom lady
gave me some extra food to bring home
with me because you had to rely on
everybody yeah yeah i did and i wanted
to be reliable to them too
oh he is reliable
and ready to answer a call
no matter who's calling
or where it's coming from you never know
who you're going to be able to help out
there if you're just open to it we are
our brother's keepers it's our
responsibility to make sure
you know our neighbors taking care of
our children our family and if we all do
that for each other then we're going to
be fine i think what the world is
missing is love
oh my gosh david i'm thinking i need to
come lay on your couch because that's
right i love the exchange that you had
between you and stephen and there was
also something very touched by stephen
just when he said that he could hear
something in his voice that he knew that
he could intuitively pick up on that i
like what the brother said stephen is
indeed a top man don't you think he's a
top man yeah david that was incredible
interview it was almost like he was
discovering along with you what was
really behind this incredible act and
how he's led his life
you know tony it was a privilege to sit
there and listen to his story because i
always like to say that we as humans
connect through weaknesses right i can't
relate to talking to a scammer and
saying hey call me back but i can relate
to pain and suddenly that story became
real relatable to
to the audience and even my my team in
the room watching i i'd love to tell you
what the boys want to do by the way so
prince who's still living in ghana wants
to come to louisiana study criminal
justice and actually work as a police
officer in the area where steven adams
and his family live isaac the brother
who spent christmas with the adams
family he's still at howard he's having
a little trouble paying the meal plan so
he may have to dump out of howard and
he's planning to potentially move to
louisiana and enroll in college
here
david what i love about your pieces like
gil said they turn into therapy sessions
and
one thing i took away from that is your
prior pain if channeled properly can
turn into something special a gift for
someone else the if the if is the big
question david you talk to people in
this situation all the time and some
people turn it into love and other
people don't for some reason what do you
think that reason is what's the
difference maker
i think if you're able to and you're
willing to you start to feel the benefit
of what is that gift because to give
invariably is to get the joy that comes
from it and i think that's what stephen
felt and to pay it forward and to see it
i hope for all of you who watched
touched you
oh it touched me very deeply i mean just
the fact that he asked a scammer to call
him back who does that number one number
two i want to go back to the brother for
just a second is he dropping is he
possibly dropping out just because he
can't pay the meal plan or is there
something more to it than that
the meal plan payment is is a real
struggle right now so he's trying to
work through that
i think people maybe the cbs family can
help him out with that david you're our
gift to us thank you so much